mike is with us in new york city to
start off this hour hey mike how are you
i'm doing well dave and yourself better
than i deserve sir how can i help
all right so uh essentially i had a
you know a couple questions uh i i
graduated from college here
on may of 20 um a pandemic grad didn't
get to have graduation but
i think they mailed me the diploma so i
guess that counts uh
so i racked up about 146
000 undergrads
23 of that was public the rest was
private
it gave me anxiety in college you know i
got out i was
fortunate enough to get a job uh out of
school um i've refinanced the private
one twice down from about seven percent
to like three point three eight so
that's
great good what's your degree in
uh finance um so
i work in financial services um so i
have for the last nine months
so i i live at home uh so
uh luckily i was uh you know fortunate
enough to discover your program
uh as a young person with a lot of debt
and fresh out of school
um you know i got you know like i said i
got a job and uh
i make about uh post tax about 3 500 a
month
uh of that i'll put 14.50
bi-weekly towards the debt so
about 2 900 a month and then they give
me a little bit about two grand a year
so
it's about four over three thousand a
month i pay back
uh so like in nine months i paid off by
32
it sounded like 114 so i probably paid
off like 32 000
so good for you that's yeah that's good
that's good so
my question for you essentially is a
couple things
um you know i
don't want to live at home like for a
long time
i have a long-distance girlfriend who's
four hours away
um and i'd like to be closer here at
some point
my question to you and something i
wrangle with right i have a good
situation
here i'm able to shovel a lot of money
um
but i also feel like if i move out i i
elongate my timeline because i'm not
paying rent i am fortunate
enough to have that so i wrestle with
like
do i stay at home am i stumping my
personal growth
should i go and chase like i went to
school down south
i'd love to live down south but like
also that incurs
rent and other expenses and things like
that so i'm just
torn like whether to stay at home's on
25 26 at the blistering pace where's
the uh where's the girlfriend
she lives in dc okay is that where
you're talking about going
is that down south for you no no no no
i'd like to go to uh like a southern
city like uh
charlotte charleston uh nashville
something like that charlotte charlotte
and nashville are both
really strong financial centers so uh
you don't make a lot of money um
i'm just kind of surprised uh but i mean
are you on some kind of a quick upward
track with your career
yeah i mean i you know i
hopefully i i expect to be promoted in
the next like
three to six months yeah what what
exactly are you doing
um essentially it's it's a basically a
financial advisor
uh training program so get licensed you
know oh okay so you're
you're running on a stipend until you
get a client base built
yeah essentially so like uh you know
it's more of like an assistant
you know to the person yeah then once
you you know gets it get some uh
you know traction then you start talking
hey mike what's your payoff date
right now if you stay at home if i stay
at home
with about a hundred so quick math say i
always like check
that you know what i'm hoping for the
best for expecting the worst like
if i just stayed at this salary right
yeah it would be and i paid bi-weekly
it's about 40 grand a year so it's about
two and a half years if i pay bi-weekly
and
i'm i can confidently say that i'm like
trying to do it in two years like
but like you're over analyzing this man
bottom line is you got to weigh the two
and a half years if you stay home stay
where you are
and you know your income's going to go
up so you've done kind of your least
amount of income scenario yeah so if you
move
south or dc whatever that looks like you
start making more money you just got to
start running the numbers and
really truly look at how much more would
it elongate using your work
it won't i don't think it's very much at
all i don't think it's much at all
because
and so here's what amounts to do i put
my entire life on hold for two and a
half years
including stepping out as an adult and
having my own place
or do i step into some of these things
like a new position and you start
shopping for that use ken coleman's
materials and land
that in the city that you want to be in
um
and making even more or making or the
chance to make the same but at a lower
cost of living than new york city
and the new york city market whatever it
is and so
because charlotte is less expensive than
new york city or the area
around new york city for sure or
nashville would be or dallas would be
so yeah i think you got to make these
moves um
and and the truth is that what will
happen
inside of your soul will cause you to
make more money because you're living
your life man
uh and um and instead of like
you know i'm just i'm i'm you know
you're you're you are you're getting
caught up in
uh addition type math rather than
multiplication type math yeah it's
really well said and so i i want you
know because i think when you
you know engage this relationship with
this lady
you uh engage your dreams
uh you are on your own you're out there
leaving the cave kill something drag it
home
you're gonna blossom in ways you're not
gonna blossom in your other scenario
that are going to
affect your income and so the net net is
probably
not any elongation but even if it is so
what do it anyway yeah we're talking
about a small amount of time as young as
you are
here's the other thing you're not
married you got the long-distance
girlfriend work a second job
yeah knock the baby steps i mean get
after it man and
i think that two and a half years can
shrink substantially if you get after it
yeah the safe course is seldom the best
course
yes i say that all the time we have a
world dave that
we've been trained to do the safe
smart decision and i got a bunch of
adults who call the ken coleman
every day that did safe and smart and
they're miserable at 35 and 45 and what
i mean by that to explain that to you
folks is that
we get taught that we got to go to the
safe college get the safe major
to get a safe job if you're not more
attractive to this young lady when
you're out there on your own in the wild
swinging
you're certainly more attractive to her
dad
that is great perspective there i didn't
see that but that's a very good point
that's a really good point you know so
you come in sit down at my table ask for
my daughter's hand and bless
in marriage yeah and you're in your
mama's basement or you're out there
swinging and you're scared to death and
you're fighting and you're scratching
and you're clawing
it's a different conversation bubba that
might be two out of three strikes with
dave ramsey i know